hey if you haven't already got it get
yourself a copy of answer the Internet
the card game it's available right now
in the link in the bio or you can get a
bar salal Mart Amazon or Spencer Gifts
play along with us
I'm Shane Gillis and this is answer the
internet would you rather have the
ability to drink with no hangover be
able to pool any girl at the bar or
become friends with Joe Pesci definitely
not friends with Joe Pesci [ __ ] the guy
first of all he's a [ __ ] in every
movies and he literally seems like the
worst guy possible to hang out with
I would definitely drink with no
hangover for sure pull any girl who
cares
I'm 32 the hangovers are like I'm
starting to get to the point where I
need to quit drinking and it sucks
really yeah how old
no hang oh my it's not like necessarily
the physical ship but the depression and
the anxiety would you rather take on a
mama lion with just a dagger or a pack
of eight wolves with just eight bullets
and a gun you gotta go wolves you got to
go wolves a lion will [ __ ] you a lion is
definitely gonna kill you a hundred
percent a dagger a hundred percent the
lion would kill you the wolves they
written the rules will run off the loser
run off you shoot like all you have to
do is kill like two of them but but if
you had to decide to get killed by a
lion or eight dogs I think you gotta go
lying because that seems like it might
be slightly quicker
just getting torn apart by dogs would be
[ __ ] yo did you see that there's a
lady at the Pittsburgh Zoo
she dropped her eye it's not that funny
it's not funny
she put her [ __ ] a three off she's
pretty three-year-old up on the edge of
the enclosure to take a picture and they
fell into the wild dogs cage and so then
that I guess the onlookers had to answer
this question they're like should I jump
in and fight eight dogs to save a
three-year-old and everybody said no
everyone was like you know what those
dogs deserve that three-year-olds it's a
nice treat for dogs at the zoo everyone
smile you get a three-year-old can you
still go to your barber if he is very
racist yes yes Jews damn that's like
real wait where is somebody complaining
about Jews that's a hairdresser has to
be in a I don't know that's weird I
don't know yeah I complain about Jews
while you're cutting yes usually I don't
know face racism doesn't know I would
definitely de yeah yes I'm I'm rich have
you seen the news who would win in a
fight
Allen Iverson her Yao Ming she [ __ ]
[ __ ] um who would win in a fight
yeah I Dan that's actually really I
guess Allen Iverson how tall is AI
though
are they what it how are they just
straight-up fight ming younglings also
he's also athletic for a big man right
you know i mean it's not just some giant
sure you guys are very random on this I
appreciate this I said I didn't read it
yet but I see a guy holding swords do
you think you could beat any creature on
earth if you had two samurai swords
absolutely not
any creature on earth no I [ __ ]
animal what do you think I think I could
kill any dog which is what which is what
samurai swords are built for that's just
a joke is god dammit that's not great
it's not great for me if you were
murdered who would be the most likely
suspect you got a lot of them now
I got about one point four billion
suspects I don't know who the [ __ ] if
somebody killed me yeah I would imagine
somebody at a show I'll tell you who you
gotta worry about is this is the right
wing those death threats I got a bunch
of death threats the right wing ones now
cuz I've made a joke about Trump getting
shot and just right away got like real
death threats for like people that like
hey [ __ ] I got ya yeah yeah yeah
who's more dominant Kenyans and
marathons or Indians is smelling these
ah damn
I think Indians bro I think it's not
even close which you would think
truthfully I think you would think
Asians would make it strong push in the
spelling bees and I you don't see them
too often news seems like a layup but
Indians do just what
well now you shut up dude I don't see
like a [ __ ] Saudi Arabian or a
Russian and be like look at that Asian
no trust me when I was targeting the
Asians it's not targeting Russians but
god damn dude see this is what happens I
can't not do it I can't not do it
who's more down at canyons a man of the
Indians Indians are [ __ ] unstoppable
[Music]
no yeah yeah is every Indian autistic is
that how they're doing this they don't
have vaccines um that's not the
correlation if you had to win a game
show to stay alive which game show would
you choose I have American Ninja Warrior
I think I could make it now I uh
damn win a game show well what's it
[ __ ] just a pure luck one good
jeopardy I think I would do I would get
murdered
yeah real fortunate crisis right is just
an absolutely yeah yeah price is right I
would just price is right just listen to
somebody in the audience Oh like like
that autistic guy did you watch that
show it's on I think it's on Netflix
there was just a guy that was showing up
to [ __ ] prices right and he was the
point of the show was like wow isn't
this guy incredible it's like no he was
just an autistic guy that got obsessed
with prices right and made a computer
program with he had a spreadsheet with
every price of every bidded you know all
of everything they bid on he had the
price to any memorized to every item and
then would sit in the audience didn't
even go on the show would sit in the
audience and yell out the [ __ ]
correct answer like everyone was like
are we
who's gonna let this autistic I ruin the
price no you watch the buzzer dude no
dude he actually yeah they started to be
like I well we gotta get this guy you
got take him out which group is worse
hey the people who clapped during a
movie or be the people who clap when
they airplane lands geez I think those
are the exact same people right those
have to be the yeah that Venn diagram is
the exact same people who clapped erm I
haven't experienced the clap during a
movie I just got hit with it I saw 1917
in a sold-out theater and people clapped
at the end or at the end Oh people clap
during a movie that seems like a you
know white people don't get enough [ __ ]
talk no no no black people don't clap
during a movie five people doing other
activities if answering phones are
talking why do people clap during a
movie that should be the question which
group is worse people who - the phone
during a movie or people who clap during
a movie and I would say people who clap
there's the whites the whites clapping
during a movie sucks that this corny as
it guess